so this is officially my first down the
middle that i walked into i stumbled
into because i got stuck in traffic
in new york city coming back from a tv
studio
all i can say is you're in for a treat
you're going to get to watch me walk
into my own set
with peter bookvar with barry ritholz
two legends two brothers of mine if i
was jewish they would be my brothers but
what i want for you to do is
watch this one to the very very end we
get a great repartee between me and
peter and barry and they're like
obviously the brothers from different
mothers but watch this one to the end
because the guidance the life guidance
that barry red holtz provides in the
very end is so worth your time down the
middle hi how are you this is barry this
is peter they're like they're like my
brothers trust me can i tell you google
them can you can i tell you how wrong i
was about doing this here this is very
civilized this is great i just pictured
the last few times we were here it was i
meant it was
it was madness no when i when i was
interviewing arthur there were three
women in from brooklyn getting just just
middle of the afternoon drunk off their
keisters
and then whoever was ringing the bell at
the new york stock exchange is behind us
and you hear champagne bottles pop pop
pop pop
drinking with danielle arthur was like
like zone he was zen he just talked his
way right through it and i'm like
and he refused to film anywhere else but
his character
no okay he's not giving him because i
have some
some savings of his in
i bet i bet yeah he always walks out
today throws hundred dollar bills leaves
and says yeah
somebody's gonna leave someone here to
change another day yeah i've been
begging him to write a book of his
recollections and he keeps threatening
to get in line
i remember your attempts yeah
yeah i actually attempted to do it i i
attempted to i offered to do it i
brought him on stage and
interviewed him at a conference and had
it
transcribed and put on the blog i'm like
arthur look how awesome this is
just you just need someone to talk to
and they'll record it because you don't
have to sit in front of a screen
you have to type danielle was like you
just talk and i will light everything
down for you just tell me his stories
are the greatest oh my god the stock
market crash the day kennedy was
assassinated the tiffany story i love
the tiffany story i love the
um cuban missile crisis oh gosh and one
of one of he tells the story that one of
the posts i remember was uh
ramen or mcdonald douglas or boeing but
it was one of the big defensive guys
they speak to the company all the time
hey i'm here for my guys the russian
missiles are on the way and art runs
around and says i gotta get a short off
i gotta get a short off and this is
coming
goes to his boss and says
i heard a rumor the missiles were coming
i tried to get a shirt off i couldn't
couldn't find any takers and the boss
says buy me a drink and i'll tell you
why you're worried yeah yeah yeah yeah
and he buys him a drink and he says when
you haven't heard this one no i know you
hear the missiles are coming you don't
want to get short you want to get long
it's long did a nuclear conflaturation
he goes there's one or two options
either the rumor isn't true in which
case the market's going to bounce the
next that day or it's nuclear war and
then who's going to settle your trade
or
he's the best
tylenol oh my gosh i mean they go on and
on and on remember when tylenol got yeah
poisoned whatever yeah yeah he's got a
chicken
is the reason why we have uh tamper
proof tops yeah and they are like a
harvard business study explanation of
here's how you respond to a crisis you
come out you apologize you explain what
what happened you explain what you're
going to do next and then you do what
you say and you're completely
transparent and that becomes the model
can we
export that harvard case study to the
eccles building to the federal reserve
sure let's talk about the fed i mean no
no but just apply your ration your
rationale to
the mit mafia at the fed the mit mafia
so i think you guys harbor a different
perspective as to what's going on and
i'd like to hear no no no no no no no no
no wait
let's lay out well hey peter's leaving
earlier than you are so okay
yours
yeah i'm dying to hear this
okay
so the mistake the fed has made
um was that they stayed on an emergency
footing too long
and should have moved off
the problem with that
and now we have overwhelming evidence
that what i'm about to say is true
is that following the 0809 great
financial crisis there was a dearth of
fiscal stimulus which meant
the fed was operating with one hand
behind the back yeah there's 787 billion
dollars it was nothing temporary
extension of uh tax cuts unemployment
insurance it was like 200 and something
it was six percent we we
we pumped 43.2 of usgdp into the veins
of consumers in 12 months right in fact
the new deal was forty point one percent
for god's sake i showed a chart a week
or two ago that showed in april 2020
unemployment insurance payouts were 1.4
trillion dollars trillion you're giving
somebody twenty five hundred dollars an
extra week to not work on top of their
unemployment balance a month extra month
but that was that was a four thousand
really it could be like it could be the
next communist regime it could have been
a week 4 900 increase it has since
fallen 98 to 27 billion dollars so
the fed should have gotten off emergency
footing they were fearful
that remember from let's call it 09 2010
to
2014
2015 um
subpar gdp subpar job creation no wage
gains subpar retail sales
and so the fed was afraid that if they
normalized they would have a low grade
recession that was going to be
persistent and they'd be cutting rates
again because congress failed to do
their job and substitute federal
government spending for households and
business so now fast forward a decade
and we have the pandemic where you have
massive monetary stimulus and even
bigger fiscal stimulus
and so the fed i believe the fed wants
to a
normalize rates get off this emergency
footing
b
they're aware of inflation but they're
also aware that the vast majority of
inflation and this is where i think we
might disappoint oh boy the vast
majority of inflation
is not going to be especially sensitive
to rate increases and therefore
by the time we get to a year from now
inflation not only is falling but the
economy is slowing and they're going to
be back on a potentially
stable maybe outside chance of cutting
in 2023 okay we're in a very different
place but forget the forecast the
environment is
fed increases aren't going to get chips
here any faster it's not going to get
any more houses built to reduce that
it's not going to do anything about the
war the russian invasion of ukraine the
big drivers of inflation
are not caused by
low rates at least that's how well but
they were on a third of the damn
mortgage market give me a break
so
credit easing was never in their mandate
credit easing was actually
it specified in the 1913 federal reserve
bank that the fed is not allowed to be
to be entangled in any way shape or form
with a government-sponsored enterprise
it says it in the in the language
and you know i mean waller didn't
dissent i'm gonna
waller if you could hear me why didn't
you dissent bullard didn't bowler
descendants
but remember
so while you're
last thing and then i'm going to shut up
and let you guys talk
so if the fed really he said for the
first time ever if i always say it i
just never do it if the fed really
thought that they were capable of
halting inflation
you had a meeting a month ago they did
nothing done zero you had inter market
six weeks nothing done they could have
done 50 bips
the fed's action i i didn't hear i did
not hear jerome powell's um pressure
today so all i'm doing is looking at
their behavior and their behavior says
yeah inflation is not a big deal most of
it's behind us
inflation will be much lower a year from
now that's what he said
so oh did he say that really well that's
what he well that's what their behavior
certainly looks like right well they're
presenting a hopes and wishes strategy
they're hoping inflation goes down
because
their credibility has been shot i do
want to say 0809 after the financial
crisis is that at least i believe that
that capitalism has an amazing
regenerative ability to
rise from the ashes resiliency yes
and
it doesn't need all this outside fiscal
monetary stimulus so when you said well
we didn't get the fiscal stimulus
outside of the you know that trillion
dollar spending and it was all on the
fed well it didn't have to all be on the
fed the the the american economy could
have regenerated itself on its own it
can function on its own and the question
is does qe
result in faster economic growth well
there's no impairable
study that there is right it influences
it can drag out expansions to where you
have the zombies alive for longer you
can do that
it influences the capital markets more
than the actual economy sure so so the
key word there is zombie and where you
and i i know are in agreement
is
maybe you don't need fiscal or monetary
if we're not too far from this really
handsome building with columns
uh called the bankruptcy court and if we
would have let various banks and brokers
thank you
do a pre-packaged bankruptcy where
maybe the us government is the only one
who could has enough money to be debtor
in possession to finance it and then
spin them all out then you maybe you
don't need as much monetary
accommodation as much fiscal
accommodation and you have a uh you
shake up the etch a sketch i know half
your audience won't know what that means
but you do a restart and off you go to
the races
barring that and what a surprise
when you have an industrialist as
treasury secretary
the bankers tend to get punished when
you have a banker
as treasury secretary guess guess who
wins guess who loses so there was also
so bernanke claimed that he was a
student of the depression he was a
student of japan
and there was experience but he repeated
the same mistake as the bank of japan
the whole point of stimulating whether
it's
the same mistake i'll explain i'll
explain how
the the whole point of stimulation of
fiscal and monetary is to try to bring
forward economic activity and say you
know what barry i'll make a deal with
you i'm going to lower interest rates
today so you can buy that house today
because you'll have a lower monthly
payment instead of you spending 12
months saving up for a down payment and
having to pay a little more so i'm
pulling forward okay so there gets a
point where if interest rates are just
low for a while there's a lot of
diminishing returns right you you
disincentivize you you don't create no
emergency right so that's japan having
rates low for forever and that was the
flaw forward guidance the fed was saying
they thought stimulation was i'm going
to tell the world we're going to keep
rates low for for a long time ended up
being at zero for seven years well you
just you discourage activity because
yeah rates are going to be low i can
wait i don't need to do anything
and
that creates sort of a uh
uh
i'm trying to think of the right word
but it just creates this incentive well
this incentive but also a rot within the
economy when rates are just low forever
i mean it just shouldn't be that way
there should be more volatility in where
rates go depending on where the supply
and demand for money is there should be
more volatility in the u.s economy as a
whole i mean
it used to be i mean that's so creative
destruction so here's the caveats to
that and and you you and my position are
not all that far apart the two caveats
are really wrinkles on this the first is
japan and most people are unaware the
japanese bubble leading up to 1980 time
5x it was the nasdaq bubble in 2000.
the the s p was 99 times compared to 40
at the people and they also had a real
estate bubble too they had 2 000 and
2008 at the same time right and their
structure is such that the karitsu in
japan
you have my favorite example you have
bank of mitsubishi you have mitsubishi
real estate holdings you've mitsubishi
heavy industry mitsubishi ornaments and
so if the bank at the bottom dies you
lose everything the whole thing
collapses so they were unable to do that
the second issue and i think this is
really important is the 0809 crisis was
caused by many factors one of which was
the abandonment of traditional
underwriting
standards by non-bank lenders and
eventually by 06 fannie and freddie were
petitioning their regulator and let them
but bio6 was all over but they're crying
hold that aside
when we went through a series of changes
and you had zero percent interest rates
and lots of people in homes that were
financed for more than worth and people
who haven't seen wage increases or lost
jobs
many many many of these people were
unable to take advantage of these low
rates
and that's the bottom third half 60
percent of the country so
the the sort of disincentive the lack of
urgency
was in the top quarter of the top 30 40
of the home buyers
and they didn't care because all of
their other assets
real estate stocks bonds were all
appreciating so well who cared what the
cost of that is one more point and then
please no so when you think about you're
the guest also when you when you lower
interest rates
what what the experience of the last 10
plus 2 10 plus years is that the biggest
beneficiaries of the lower interest
rates has been the capital markets it's
been those that have been able to tap it
real assets capital markets well i'm
talking about decile so if i'm trying to
stimulate the economy i want banks to
utilize and companies
banks to utilize their lending ability
companies to take advantage of cheap
money to borrow
businesses borrowing bills the problem
is that when you when you when you lower
interest rates across the yield curve
you depress loan margins okay so if i'm
a local regional bank that is supplying
the blood to small medium-sized
businesses
i have less margin i ca i need i can't
make as many mistakes because i have
less loan margin because of what the fed
has done you look at the japanese
regional banking system has been
destroyed over the last 30 years
because of the lack of lending margin so
if you go to a bank right now
and i i and and i know from experience
it is it's very difficult to get a loan
personal guarantee
uh years of of experience of in a
particular field where if you went to
wall street
six months ago before the markets sold
off it was extraordinarily easy so
small and medium-sized businesses get
hurt by the lack of basic
lending that banks are supposed to be in
business of doing
not expanding their portfolio of us
treasuries which is is much bigger than
cni loans and by the way
i got two words for you
private equity
the expansion of private equity to a
multi-trillion dollar business stepped
into that void because the marketplace
will not be denied and if there's a
demand for a product
if the banking system doesn't want to
provide it well then blackstone and
carlisle will work you smaller than that
so how much smaller are you talking
about
so so a a friend and a business that
i've invested in they opened up a
franchise children's swim school
uh pre-covered so we're talking okay
very small business but i'm sorry here's
a perfect example yeah wells fargo has a
franchise lending division no problem
you've never done this before in your
entire life but you know what you're
good credit obviously personal
guarantees were involved but they got
the loan right then they wanted to open
up a second one after having a very six
house for the first time
yeah and it was ten times more difficult
to get that loan you had to have a
certain number of uh of uh of customers
before uh that before you even opened
you had to sign up the the hurdles were
so much greater at the same time
like i said it was very easy to get a
loan in the capital markets and
i think that impacting bank
profitability
impacts their
uh their ability to land i mean look at
the european banks
ecb did it to european banks 80 percent
of lending in europe is through their
banking system and what the ecb do it
crushed their ability to make money and
not only that they were taxing them for
the reserves they held at the ecb god
bless you some negative interest rates
right so i think big companies they're
gonna go into two recessions without
ever raising rates above very small and
medium-sized businesses they get hurt
because they're a local banker it's just
not as friendly right about now
someone's supposed to say crypto fixes
this
oh no
so
i i i'm not disagreeing with you my my
personal experience i remember
refinancing a house in o5
and literally the guy pulled up in the
driveway flung the door open
left the car running ran in signs sign
initial initial here's your check oh
yeah and left and that was maybe it was
04. i remember looking at my wife saying
this has to end badly he's like i
apologize i have a closing down the
street in 2013 when we bought the house
drive by refinancing for me for me
making a nice living with a wife who's
been the same job for 20 plus years and
a good credit score the hoops we had to
jump through to get a mortgage
and admittedly it was
slightly jumbo it wasn't a super gym it
was slightly jumbo but still it was a it
was months and months and months longer
and i'm thinking
i have access to capital i have money in
my bank account what happens if someone
just wants to do a refi of a half a
million dollar house
they're [ __ ] they're never going to be
able to get this done and that's been
part of the entire 2010 to 2020
period it's it's not any one president
it's not any one administration it's not
anyone fed
i argue that
when
households and businesses
decrease their spending substantially i
don't mean 10 20
i mean when it it drops 30 40 50
as lord keynes taught us the government
should temporarily step in and make up
for that demand temporarily temporarily
but that demand was never there's two
things there's capital to buy things and
then there's the cost of that capital
the fed is in charge of the cost that
capital yeah what we learned with the
cares act in 2020 and the second cares
act in 2020 and the third one in 2021
is if you put money into people's
pockets
they'll go out and spend all of it and
that's right and the amazing thing is if
you look at if you look at the network
form of cash for clunkers though it
creates a temporary stimulus to the
economy that then fades away yeah
inflation into a war well yeah it
created this because the demand was
stayed for longer or cash for clunkers
is over a short period of time i was in
europe europeans were this is in october
they're like
what were you thinking america you've
given us inflation you you stimulated
your economy so much you stimulated the
whole global economy you have this
inflation keep in mind the the two
things about inflation that i think
people sort of forget
the u.s is a predominantly service-based
economy versus good based yeah it's like
61
39 something like that until the
lockdown when you weren't going on
vacation you weren't going out to dinner
you weren't going to the gym think all
this all the services that you stopped
doing
so you started buying stuff for the
house you bought a
an outdoor furniture set and a fire pit
and a big tv
you're buying all this food and all this
stuff so
uh i think it was um
rebecca patterson of bridgewater yeah
said
you know the amazing thing is that
global gdp increased five percent during
the pandemic the problem is that demand
for goods increased uh 20 percent
and so a lot of this was just people are
locked in the house giving them money
enable that though because a lot of
these are big ticket items where people
had to borrow money to build a deck and
they had to borrow money to buy a car
via the the zero rates that the fed
created so the fed was a demand driver
here in a lot of these things when you
think about the what's the average price
what you're looking at
45 4 000 and the median income was 150.
but the fed's been at zero for seven
years and you didn't have a giant spike
up in homes you never giants
combination exactly exactly you cannot
look at it in a vacuum
it was the same
underwriting effectively all the
stimulus so had there been a
had there been a fiscal stimulus of
appropriate size
half of what we did in 2020 back in
0-809 you would have had a better and of
course the bankruptcies but i think no
one there was no appetite for that but
it would have been a healthier recovery
you would have had far fewer lagging
wages the way we did yeah um and this is
true both in the us and globally when
you look at the entire world's inflation
it's this is why i'm always reluctant to
to pin everything on the federal reserve
because the whole world was locked down
and the whole world had some form of
stimulus and people spent that money and
guess what yeah spending a ton of money
is going to be inflationary right but it
was quantifiable to how much money we
should have given out we just said okay
this is how much lost income people are
experiencing right let's just refill the
lost income what we did is we did that
and then a lot on top of that and it was
right that all that gravy and cherry on
top that created the inflation as
opposed to just making people whole
again right
you've lost three million workers
between the ages of
25 and 45. three million have dropped
out of the workforce that's a big number
ask yourself why
because they had enough to live on
and still where are they now how do they
you know 2500 a month for a year seeing
levels
three years of we're seeing labor force
participation come way up and you saw it
the minute that last child tax credit
was delivered in cash your labor force
participation went whoop
so so on the terms of the labor force
i'm gonna bring up i don't disagree with
that but you have four other factors
that are giant
first
decrease in immigration had immigration
not started to fall true um not only but
during the previous administration but
this administration as well it clearly
started under trump but this
administration has done nothing to
reverse it that's two million missing
jobs
people over 60 massive early retirement
um
[Music]
health care uh and child care you have
people who who
basically were forced to stay home and
take care and it's mostly women by the
way i'm aware um and then the the fourth
thing and i i find this kind of
fascinating
is
i i've been talking about this for a
while and i always loved it on those
rare occasions where you're ahead of
everybody else picking this up elvis
left the building a long time ago when
you have people locked at home for a
year and you give them enough money to
live on a lot of them are going to
upskill they're going to get degrees
they're going to get new vocations
they're going to launch new businesses
apps consulting whatever so
i don't think the bls is picking up a
lot of these that's the that's the
silver lining and there was just the
wall street journal that's why the
unemployment rate's falling a lot yes
that's capturing that yeah absolutely
yeah so okay so so much for me shutting
up yeah that worked
um
what should jay pal do
he has to accept
and tolerate a period of time when we
have slower growth that's notable
because monetary policy is only
affecting the demand side
but you need to moderate the demand side
you there are less cars to buy you need
to convince people not to buy cars
through
higher price increases of borrowing yeah
no through price increases automotive is
saying that people are pushing back
because of the price right we're already
seeing that it's because that's the
fallacy of running things hot because
then you you flame out and that's the
same thing with housing you need to
subdue the demand side to lower the rate
of these home price increases to allow
people to afford i mean when you when
you see home price increases that are so
fast that it offsets the benefit of
lower mortgage rates that's a real
problem the lowest supply of inventory
ever
not on the new home side
well we're back so so let's talk about
new homes
peter's got to leave in a few minutes oh
that's right
because senator shelby asked him are you
willing to be paul brooker and he said i
hope history remembers me that way yeah
he's not and
give me a break okay so this is where we
are we're likely headed because he's
acknowledged we're gonna i'm gonna be
double tightening again
he even said that mate yeah qt can start
he came up with a whole new phrase for
watching paint dry and i'm like
so
qt we know impacts
markets and right p ratios call it maybe
meaning reducing their balance sheet
right and
rate hikes will impact the demand side
of the economy so he's going to be
tightening financial conditions at the
same time he's going to be slowing the
economy you know magically in his
projections they're gonna take the fed
funds rate from zero to almost three and
the unemployment rate will stay at three
and a half percent yeah how about that
work out the first time you try magic
dust but
um
he needs to
he needs to start he should have raised
50 today because 50 is nothing
when when inflation's at eight raising
there's 703 basis points defense rate is
703 basis points and behind the market
has given him some rope the market has
said jay we're giving you seven hikes
so just just get get by the way what has
the market been forecasting about fed
rate increases for the past decade
they've been
far more hawkish than the fans oh
right so when the market says we predict
seven hikes it's like you've been
talking it's what they predict today
there's a demand side viewpoint for a
lot of people with respect to monetary
policy a lot of these phds they look at
the economy from a demand side lens
and not look at the supply side and the
demand side lens so
they they are overly reliant and getting
back to my point about the the ability
of the american economy and just
capitalism generally to regenerate is
they are overconfident in their
abilities they think low rates good high
rates bad well flow rates are good even
lower rates are even better and if we
get to zero if you're in europe let's go
to negative because that has to be the
best
and the there there are too
confident in their abilities to
influence the economy and then they
overstay their welcome and then the law
of diminishing returns and all the
distortions and so on and then when it's
time to pull out they're in so deep it
creates disturbances when they try to
leave they're trapped why do you guys
think the united states is the only
major economy that didn't have negative
interest rates
because it would have blown up the u.s
money market industry which is four to
five trillion and that you would have
blown up that then in turn you would
have blown up the commercial paper
market you would have done such damage
plus other other countries had to
substitute in the treasury rate because
if you if you pop that negative people
into the black shoals model it's like
not defined so so that the reason i
asked that is if you really believe that
the fed thinks low rates good lower
rates bad better why wouldn't they have
gone negative because of what i just
said so you think a few trillion dollars
stands between them and even better
rates the whole plumbing of the us
financial system yeah
it is it's a different system and yet no
i'm aware and look what's happened to
europe i mean the the equity value of
european banks that are down 75 percent
from its pekin 07 right
how are you going to create a healthy
foundation for growth
when you do that to your banking so so
the point i'm raising is if there's a
line that the fed won't cross because
they know the ramifications of that line
breaking credit what we're really
talking about is where does the fed
believe that line is so danielle you're
saying they think it's at zero
i think it shouldn't be danielle for
years and i gave her a lot of credit for
saying this post-financial crisis
when the feds started lifting interest
rates said that they should never go
below one percent that's interesting the
floor should be higher
why
the floor should be higher because it
encourages banks to lend you got to have
some curve in the yield
and if you go down to zero all kinds of
[ __ ] starts to break we've seen you you
encouraged you really i mean like it
used to be called heras now it's called
caesars
i mean you've got you've got companies
you've got companies that are around you
that should have long since got away and
it also should relate to you know
lending a low of rate of inflation
you're almost guaranteeing that on a
real basis i'm going to lose money right
on a low yeah and how do you how does
that transfer that's why apartment
buildings are trading hands at two
percent cap rates
i'm like you gotta be kidding me there's
been a bunch of other laws that that
affected that barry good to see you
again man okay so your twitter feed my
twitter feed when canada seized
appropriated funds from the truckers
you saw the rage on twitter
no i didn't i i first of all i didn't
know what the truckers were protesting
we talked about rule of law before yeah
if you're gonna bring your tractor
trailer on in front of my house then i'm
gonna tow that thing away and slap you
upside your head when you do it and the
question is why did it take them 21 days
that i don't get they they should have
done that much sooner
and and the convoy
it's kind of uh they're coming to dc
yeah yeah how about that you really want
to stay talking about trudeau
seizing people's bank accounts
i was not tracking that okay
so that was kind of so there was there
was a lot of awareness
and then is this a true thing or is this
a twitter thing no it's a true thing so
do they have a law and a process by
which they can do it or is it preemptive
like the u.s allowing police departments
to seize cash
if they allege it's the result of a
crime even though they have no proof
and it's even gotten as bad as people
going to buy cars
army guys in uniform have had cash taken
from them the u.s forfeiture rules it's
one thing when you're convicted of a
crime it's another thing when they say
we're gonna assume a pile of cash is
criminal
u.s does that
well what i'm getting at is
there was a lot of outrage yeah you
can't you can't do that you can't go and
take away my money blah blah blah what's
the law say what's the rule of law as
it's applied did government act
appropriately or did they violate the
law i think trudeau bent the law is the
situation so
what i'm getting to is
very few people in our little universe
were kind of the hair stood up in the
back of their neck when
when we seized russian central bank
reserves
yeah no nobody cared about that i didn't
see anybody object to that
um i was really well you want to say
that publicly hold on stop rolling no
you sure you want to say that no
the sanctions are one thing but
if you're
if you're saudi arabia
you're like can the united states come
in because they don't like my politics
and seize my oil
no but if you invade another sovereign
nation they can and we have to be
careful not to blur the lines between
the us has mustered world opinion
because somebody did something like
versus
their [ __ ] committing war crimes
shelling citizens no no no no no no i
i'm not disagreeing with you about
anything that's going wrong in in
ukraine nothing but i mean you have to
be careful not to conflate two different
things this is the first time that
you've ever really seen a strategic
default on treasuries
by
the united states of america how did the
united states strategically default on
treasuries because they froze a hundred
billion dollars it's not a default they
they're going to interpret it as being a
default
but my question if you want to be wrong
could we do the same thing to china
i think they're too big of an economy
i don't know if we could the interesting
fallout from this and here's where you
and i are
are looking at the same thing
saudi arabia is saying hey maybe we'll
sell oil to the chinese and they've been
saying that for 10 years
the world ended in 2017 because the same
exact thing was going to happen right
but it's a whole different dynamic if i
mean
china's got more leverage
than they had before it's good yeah
china has more leverage than they had
before
bargaining with the united states
because we took this extraordinary step
we crossed a rubicon
and they've got did one point have
something point three through i ran
40 years ago sanctions
this is different iran is not part of
the rest of the global financial system
is iran part of swift no no but no they
cut i ran off swift yeah they did they
didn't they didn't cut russia off and
say okay gas problems bank can not be
cut off the system no this was a giant
[ __ ] you let's not let's not mince words
this was like
but the difference between trudeau
disciplining a bunch of unruly truckers
and what took place with russia is
to his credit
biden has put together
the most cohesive
um coalition
maybe since
since bush and even then the the
the allies went in kind of kicking and
screaming because they weren't fully
convinced
this is pretty clear hey this is on your
eastern doorstep
russian aggression is real and here's
the videotape oh yeah no no no no doubt
but i'm trying to so it's not a
unilateral u.s thing it is no no they
had they had 200 billion dollars in
euros in reserves those were seized too
so so when when
a rogue actor
gets the whole world mad at him other
than
china north korea and iran and saudi
arabia and and venezuela i guess you
might as well throw them into them well
no we sent a delegation why did god
decide to put oil in the worst places in
the world you know france you know paris
is sitting on one of the biggest
fracking shale formations on the planet
on your on your paris yes yeah no one's
no one's putting up drills and france is
like no no
all six all six
parallels
all six french banks signed a petition
that they would never land but you could
go like 30 miles outside of paris and go
in sideways but um but you know
when you look at what putin did
right and when you look at the global
response
i'm always careful of avoiding the
slippery slope and extrapolating too
much and saying
putin did this and here's the u.s
response
none of our bank accounts are safe the
u.s can take your money i'll no i'm not
drawing that distinction i'm saying
if you're xi jinping
what are you making of this in terms of
your calculus when you i mean if you
read putin's speeches and if you read
jesus speeches they talk about you know
the disgrace they've been disgraced on
the western stage
they've had their their territory taken
from them and it's rightfully theirs
you could actually switch their speeches
out for one another and they sound
really similar well taiwan and china
obviously that's what i'm that's what
i'm talking about but but i think the
takeaway
so i was not privy to any of the
conversations between biden and any of
the rest of the world
but i have to
suspect that the
subtext is whatever we are saying to
putin in his aggression
you understand that
taiwan our ally and china are going to
be watching what we say very carefully
and if i'm ji i'm looking at this and
saying well we're the second largest
economy in the world and we're one of
the fastest large
fastest growing large economies and if
we ever invaded
taiwan
i don't think they could do this to us
but
i'm gonna
from a game theory argue
that the window for china's acquisition
of taiwan he would say
xi jinping would say requisition
repatriation you know supposedly they
are very touchy about how anybody says
anything about time oh yeah you gotta
say so i guess rudolph's wealth
management isn't gonna open a beijing
branch any time but
um
you know taiwan has been an independent
country for a century plus if they blame
the british for separating it and hong
kong and everything else
um
you know the brits also cut up the
middle east in a way that has has been
problematic ever since
i think the
the window for taiwan and for one china
is closing and as much as g
appears to be
look
if if if trudeau went rogue it's our
longest um border the u.s would be a
little reluctant to you know slap true
canada around so that the relationship
between china and russia obviously a
very long northern border of course that
said
and xi jinping knows that his military
ally is not
quite as good as he thought his military
allies potemkin village much i mean
there's still a nuclear power they still
have weapons let's not let's not do that
but the vaunted
soviet uh armed forces and they took out
their own communication system
so this is this is
it's more than just a military failure
this is a logistical failure which is
how military operates which by the way
the u.s military no matter what you
think about how much we spend and
all the you know the to a man whose only
tool is a hammer everything looks like a
nail and the us has a tendency to get
into wars of choice that we really
shouldn't
all that said the us military is
really a very very
competent logistical organization badass
and when you look in fact when you look
at the muffed vaccine rollout in the u.s
that wasn't fixed by any one politician
that was fixed by a politician by saying
you guys seem to know what the hell
you're doing you do this operation warp
speed yeah and and
people don't realize we we're up to 75
percent of the over 18 population fully
vaccinated that's an amazing number and
the vast majority of that was military
logistics so
as much as i don't want to just cast
aspersions without pointing out the us
is a substantial
logistical player
you would think the soviet union has
enough practice with this but that's the
difference between
the soviet system which is thought of as
as corrupt as it is
um by people who are spoon-fed nonsense
from from so i'm calling him still
calling him soviet not russia because
modern russia is very much like the
soviets it was kgb i mean right and the
fact that
state tv is feeding them an endless
stream of [ __ ] um i got into a
little debate with someone arguing with
someone on twitter who the woman who
came on the tv show the employee and
opened the sign they're like it just
goes to show you how naive americans are
um
that was all set up that's all i'm like
i don't think so
has anybody seen if she's gone off to
the gulag no she went to went to court
they gave her a fine they let her out
which is
which this person then says see if this
was real they would have thrown her in
jail i'm like you know i don't know if
i'm
not
if i'm uh
not cynical enough or you're way too
cynical but i mean they hustled her off
the air in eight seconds i mean it
wasn't like she was there that was like
the cane
right so so anyway
i don't know if if i'm the premier of
china and i'm looking at this
not the military power i thought
certainly not the economic power they
once were not that they ever were which
is hilarious but then now
hey you're going to be a trading partner
with
these guys you're going to be bartering
goods for oil because
they don't have a whole lot of capital
anywhere
so
from a global perspective no i mean they
had
russian exports were up 72 percent
in january 72 and it all went into the
hands of a few men well but a lot of
that was was was
just oil windfall but it went straight
into the hands of the most corrupt elite
people in the country it didn't like go
to the people so here's here's the
question that some people were asking
who's wealthier bill gates or vladimir
putin
and you know by a lot of measures it was
a toss-up
ask that same question today and
arguably i don't know if putin has
access to his money because a lot of it
is outside of russia
it would have to be i mean united arab
emirates is making a play right now yeah
they're trying to be the next
switzerland
interesting so they were there they were
one of the countries that when janet
yellen proposed a 15 percent
uh global
tax minimum corporate minimum corporate
tax the uaa was like uh-huh
and because but and now there's always a
free rider there's a problem of
anti-trust there's always somebody when
everybody agrees to something there's an
advantage to not being part of that
there's no one always someone who's
going to be afraid and the uae
abstain from voting on the security
council as well because they're like
we'll take the oligarchs money and you
can come domicile in our country as well
if you get thrown out of dublin too hot
it's too hard who wants to live there
you just have to have your company
headquartered there you have to live
there oh no the oligarchs if they ever
want to see their money again they have
they got to go to uae right
none of this is coming by by any
electron there is no ach coming there's
no electronic
um wire coming so
that's what i mean it's too wide you
want to see your money you gotta the
advantage of switzerland is at least the
climate is it's lovely right it's not
that terrible so and they like the snow
i don't know how much they like the sand
but that's kind of where we're going
with this and it's pretty i don't know
is this a defining moment
is this different than other
geopolitical moments
that the markets always inevitably shrug
off
well that was the business week column i
did but
um even world war ii it took 180 days
for the market to bottom and a year
later was at all-time highs after pearl
harbor that that's a crazy thing
so
back to the art caching conversation if
this spreads to nato and becomes a
nuclear war
the trades aren't going to settle it
doesn't matter no but but if this stays
and i know this is a dirty word
contained
to the the russian ukraine
region
well crimea wasn't a defining war
moldova wasn't a defining war georgia
wasn't a defining war
the difference
here is that
ukraine borders poland ukraine is right
on european
border and the black sea and when when
you look at
that area
you know keep in mind the difference
between ukraine and georgia and moldova
is ukraine had nukes
when the soviet union fell apart yeah
and part of the deal uh the u.s brokered
of the ukrainians giving up their
nuclear deterrent
because essentially they were a
not exactly first world type of ability
to protect nuclear weapons so they don't
fall into the wrong people's hands
um
there was an agreement that the the west
would keep them safe
arguably we've abrogated that agreement
and and it's you know they were never
part of nato but there was a sort of hey
you will supply us which we've done and
we'll you'll give us weapons and yep um
we forget that in 1972
richard nixon
they came
they came out with a shanghai um
communique that basically said
one china you can have taiwan we just
passed the 50-year anniversary of that
like the united states
when he came home it was him and
kissinger in a room right and they threw
their secretary of state out of the room
right so when they got back to the
united states they're like you just did
what right
you just gave taiwan back to china well
you know i think something like that
might might require senate ratification
i don't know if nixon had the authority
to do that um not that china cares so so
back to xi
um
[Music]
yeah i mean he's this is it this is our
friend leland miller he's like he's
gonna do whatever it takes to get
through november to get that third term
and and he also said by the way
third five year term has it been 10
years already is that right
wow that's amazing so once he gets this
third one he's in for life so here's the
question
if you're looking at him
if you're you're him looking at the
world wouldn't now be the time to take
taiwan
militarily militarily they thought they
had russia with them
and the russian military machine
china has
china has a decent-sized navy a giant
army their first their first aircraft
carrier was like legos and then their
second one was like world class well you
know china is very good at um borrowing
stealing technology borrowing designs
you're so much more diplomatic
um thanks again because we're going to
be opening up rituals management in
beijing
um although really singapore is the
place to uh to go over expats are
leaving singapore in droves i thought
they were leaving hong kong forcing me
no
real bloomberg headline i missed it huh
um so so
you know your work at bloomberg you're
not supposed to miss headlines ah
there's a time there's 10 thousand of
them a day that's so i i i and that's
not where i work that's just my science
that's your sidekick um
so so here's the real question why
doesn't china just buy as much of taiwan
as they can like you would think they
would be able to between their state
private
melded enterprise you would think they
would be able to go out and buy up
half of taiwan yeah but they can't
i can't bring it home but right but you
can't go buy taiwan semiconductor
you literally can't you literally could
go buy shares and taiwan senate
conductor although i don't know what
taiwan rules you're suggesting china
does a leveraged buyout of taiwan's i
mean i think that's that's for everybody
i think if you think
not thomas semiconductor taiwan just no
i understand i'm just saying taiwan says
something there's a big chunk of it so i
love you i'm going to tell you a story
that i've never told before so
down the middle exclusive listen up so
the first person i worked for i'm not
going to mention their name
um my first job was at a firm that was
the predecessor eventually became pure
trade and um he goes to work for one of
the senior guys there
long story they spin out a company it
goes public and now it's across the
street from where we're uh
where we're we're sitting but anyway um
he used to jokingly say i'm not a
billionaire but i can see it from my
backyard um and he had a neighbor who
was a pain in the ass really didn't like
this guy
and one day they get into an argument
and the guy says if you don't like it so
much why don't you just buy my house and
he says what do you want the guy throws
out a number that he thinks is
ridiculous and he pulls out a check
writes it says how's your lawyer get in
touch with my lawyer get the [ __ ] out of
my house in 30 days like literally that
was the story and now it's just adjacent
to his yard the house is gone
right um that's very texas by the way so
you're right it's like
buy one get one free when californians
come they're like oh my god the houses
are so cheap i'm gonna buy one get one
free so so the question is
you know i know i'm not leland's the guy
to ask this question because i don't
know taiwan law i don't know china
i know but that's that's really an
interesting way of looking at it
they have become so wealthy over the
past 30 years
primarily by selling everything they can
make to the west
if they really want to buy taiwan you
don't have to invade them
make them an offer they can't refuse oh
my god financially i don't mean a
godfather offer just add another zero to
that check and now you're back to one
china look china created a municipal
bond market overnight they're like oh
god we've got to move some bad debt what
are we going to do and they're like i
know we'll create a municipal bond
market
and they just move things around i don't
i'm not in the camp that thinks that
china's going to blow up tomorrow but
i'm also not in the camp that think that
thinks that china has endless amounts of
money
they seem to have done a really good job
so so somewhere between a fully managed
economy
and a hands-off we don't need an
industrial policy economy somewhere in
the middle is a good balance between
free market and hey sometimes the free
market can't look out
forget past next quarter two decades
from now and so the idea of saying you
know a public-private partnership
uh
i love when the young men say to me
of course the private sector is better
look at look at the space exploration
i'm like you're too young to remember
that this is built on 75 years of nasa
this didn't come out of left field
exactly
so so but we forget the new deal was a
predominantly public private partnership
and it built a bunch of stuff built a
lincoln tunnel i mean it built a bunch
of stuff that was public private so that
was the piece i did in 2020 for business
week which was go big there's a
wonderful book called
uh by bu srivas sun is his name called
americana and it looks at 400 years of
american capitalism and what's so
shocking in the book is every major
innovation
has its roots in a public-private
partnership
railroads telegram um canals all these
things were initially way too big i mean
the erie canal has put this little new
york style on them
i mean right on on the map lacie hunt
tells me the story of the nickel tax
that's how that's how eisenhower built
the interstate highway system
no not a not a penny of public debt
nickel on each a gallon of gas
back when gas was 20 cents
i mean
yeah but it built the interstate highway
system
and productivity went through the roof
yeah you can move goods around the
country no i mean i've advocated for
three four trillion dollars of
infrastructure spending real
infrastructure spending look we've the
gas taxes unchanged since the early 90s
it's 30 years ago everything has gone up
more and even if electric cars
eventually become dominant that's still
a decade away at our earliest there's a
ton of cars and trucks out there should
we be drilling
drooling for what more
should we have pipelines my favorite
expression about oil came from i don't
remember who it was but it was a saudi
minister who said
because that's a waste of oil converting
it into fuel and burning it oil is much
more valuable as a material than as an
energy source it's not just plastic it's
a million other polymers and other
things that's the value of oil um but
you consume much less of it when you're
not lighting it on fire so i don't know
where the price of oil ends up when the
world is 50 ev
but it's an interesting question and
look look at the underperformance of the
you know uh
big oil companies the major oils it's
kind of suggesting other than the past
six months right but look at the past
decade um it's been a long time since
exxon mobil now they're doing gigantic
mergers and acquisitions and taking on
debt and doing it all over again wow
because they need economies of scale
because
eventually the massive demand for their
product is going to fall it's not going
to go to zero but it's going to
diminish when less and less cars are
internal combustion engines so um barry
let's just say for example and i know
this is like an outside possibility but
let's just say that whoever's watching
right now doesn't know who you are
which is impossible the youngins don't
know who i am i kind of like
like uh it's always interesting when i i
chat with somebody and then like a week
later i get an email from them it's like
i had no idea i thought i recognized
your voice it's always amusing stuff you
do have a record your voice is very
recognizable um how do you
how do you find your guests first of all
eight what is masters in business
and and well before that
where do we want to start the problem is
i'm like an octopus i got too many
things going you got your day job right
what's your day job so i'm chairman and
chief investment officer of results
wealth management we're a asset
management and financial planning firm
we manage uh just under three billion
dollars for about 1700 families okay
that's cool it's fun yeah i work with
some great people my founding partners
are josh brown michael batten and chris
venn
um all of whom have since the day i met
them continue to astonish me they're all
upside surprises you don't normally you
know draw to an inside straight like
that where each card is an ace um but
but you know lots of people know who
josh brown is oh yeah people are
starting to learn who michael batnick is
and are starting to learn who chris van
are who are both rock stars as well josh
isn't the only
um rock star in the firm so
that's the last time i saw josh was here
oh is that true last time i saw josh in
person was here with his body vance he
he's uh here usually once a week across
the street
um
so so that's the day job so what is
what's what's masters in business and
what inspired you to create it
so that's a story which i don't recall
if i've told publicly but i've certainly
said enough all right so
the the
[Music]
the arc of this is i started a blog
in the 90s on yahoo geocities where you
would have to take
google it right you would have to take
it was html it would take you a half
hour to write whatever you wanted and
then two hours to code it i got very
good at html code
in o3 i moved that to typepad which was
a wysiwyg what you see is what you get
so there was no more html coding
although it was very useful having all
that html because i could go into the
code and and make things do things that
the wysiwyg couldn't um
and then an 08 i moved that to wordpress
where it's been ever since um
my initial claim to fame and early
2000's i was writing for the street.com
i had a series called the apprentice
investor
um that did pretty well
i am
my claim to fame is in oh
was it 07 or oh six i'm in the business
week annual i get an email from somebody
hey so-and-so dropped out of the
businessweek annual forecast
would you like to jump in
and i'm like i i have a vivid
recollection of writing back and i'll
get to mrs business i have a
recollection of writing back and saying
listen nobody can really forecast here's
my column finally a forecast why don't
we do some counter program explaining
none of these people know what they're
talking about they every year it's a
different person it's totally random
blah blah blah and and they said um it's
a double issue it sells a lot of
advertising would you like to be in it
sure
so
i do my
i had just done a column for the
street.com called the cult of the bear
which was december 06 and it said listen
this rally isn't done there's a lot more
upside here's the trend here's this
here's that
however
if you read the reinhardt and rogue off
just the five crisis research paper not
the book that came out post crisis
hey
you know this financial crisis the the
if we get a financial crisis we should
expect real estate prices to full 30
percent stock prices to fall as much as
50
let's plug those numbers into the dow
and calculate
where the market will be
so
the actual number i had come up with at
the time the dow was 13 or 14 000 in
that range
was 6800 and the way i calculated 6800
was
doing the math on the crazy way the dao
was calculated 9 800 was my
earnings based down number yep but
breaking 10 would cause a 3 000 point
panic so i did dow 6800 and when i
gave that whole thing with all the
parallel to s p the i got an email back
i'm like there's a typo in your forecast
it says 6800
and it's like that's the dow forecast
and they're like okay
so it's 15 000 16 000 14 000 and then me
it's just the 800. kudlow has me on the
show excruciates me i was a regular on
cud low and he just had a field day so
the funny thing is
um we moved to all k this is pre-riddled
as well we moved to all cash in january
of 0.8 and by march of 08 suddenly um
most favored nation i'm on all these
channels and i'm getting called in every
other day come talk about oh this was
only like 12 000 11 000 but people were
freaking out the housing market was a
disaster
um
that led to the washington post which
eventually led to bloomberg and when
bloomberg i saw as a washington post
wait well
now i'm gonna it's such a long terrible
boring story yeah
so i i interviewed randy forsythe for
the show oh sure
one of the first things i remember after
i met you was the first time you were in
ellen abelson's column
yeah that was delightful you like picked
up the phone and you're like hey
did you call a relative
what no no didn't you call a relative
and say i'm in barons i'm i'm in
ableton's column
oh god this got to be the first time we
were at camp kotak anyways it's it's
it's stuck no no no i got a phone call
from a relative
saying okay that's no relative was
involved no i got a phone call from a
relative
who said to me
i understand how am i reading
barons and my cousin
is in it i'm like
you know your cousin's been on radio and
tv before
that's not the first time i've been in
the times yeah but abramson was
something else no he was a one-off and
you know
he had a bearish bias and i was the most
bearish guy in the street so it was just
at the time right right two the one
thing i'm most pleased about across the
entire breadth of my career is i said to
a buddy who
um was a well-known technician i vivid
recollection of this conversation as as
it starts to look like 11 000 10 it
looks like hey there's a chance 9
thousand
a conversation uh was please don't let
me be that [ __ ] that at seven
thousand instead of declaring victory i
double down and say three thousand oh
god no i want you to slap me across the
face if i do that he goes you're on
and and
i was away at 6 800. so when i got back
we were 6400 it's like all right i
missed my 68. i gotta i gotta honor my
thing and i went on yahoo
finance and it turned out to be by the
dumbest of luck i don't take any credit
for the timing of this the day before
the bottom oh god so so i'm pleased to
be able to be flexible enough to have
done both so
how does all that [ __ ] lead to
masters in business master's in business
so i'm i'm the finance columnist for
washington post and i'm at something at
a conference in vancouver
and i'm flying
back to new york and i have to trade
change planes in chicago and i go into
the lounge and i'm waiting for them to
call my plane
and on one of the financial channels is
bill ackman who is no hedge fund persian
square notoriously
reclusive
does not do a lot of media he comes out
every now and then
so he's not like completely you know
he's he's but he doesn't do a lot
and it was it was the worst interview
i've ever seen of any money manager so
what are your favorite stocks where's
the dow going to be in the year when's
the fed going to cut like just stuff
that has a
shelf life of 30 seconds exactly and i'm
watching this and i'm doing a slow
burn i'm like furious and they call my
plane and i leave just like i watch 15
minutes of it and i walk out and i i get
on the plane and by coincidence i bump
into someone i know sitting a row behind
us
adjacent people let us switch and he's
like why you look so you know you're
chewing your tongue and i repeat that
story and he and he said to me literally
what would you have asked him and i just
spit out like 10 questions off the top
of my head yeah which eventually became
the last 10 questions i asked every
guest which is
who are your mentors uh what are you
reading
what sort of advice would you give to a
recent college grad what do you know
today you wish you knew you know 25 30
years ago when you were started and when
bloomberg came soliciting for me to
write for them instead of the washington
post
i said look i have a platform you have a
platform why do i have to come here
and they said two things they said with
bloomberg so here's a giant pile of
money so okay you've got my attention
and then the second thing they said is
we have this fantastic platform
television would you like a television
show and i'm like
not really i i find financial television
to be
great background but not where i want to
put my efforts and i said what what
about radio i'm like go on would you
like to do something i said what i would
like to do is find
intelligent accomplished articulate
people and have an adult conversation
not three or four minutes but long form
yep and they said long form like 15
minutes i'm like no like two hours
and they laughed and laughed
and the afterwards they're like listen
to get an hour of radio we need about 43
minutes traffic news sports commercials
there's an hour
so get us 43 minutes we'll put
everything else up online
and
we'll we'll see if this is i'm like oh
so like a podcast and they're like
what do you mean i'm like let me show
you some of these other examples of
these long-form interviews this is
before podcasts were podcasts right
at the advent so arguably master's in
business was the first podcast at
bloomberg
in the beginning it was basically you
know my first i don't know 20 30 guests
i just working my way through the roller
deck you were at the fed at the time
right you were not available nope but it
was the people i personally knew it was
david kotak and rosie and
go down like everybody i knew they've
all been on down the middle right last
one it's it's
so that's how i kind of that's how you
build your network out well that was the
existing network the i think the big
name that flipped the switch was bill
gross when bill gross first came on
so two things happened with bill gross
first
when he got uh [ __ ] can from pimco
and everybody was writing all these
columns about it it was like you know
not for nothing yeah his performance has
been weak the past five years
but the guy built a trillion dollar
business over 40 years does that why is
everybody
kicking him down so on the way home the
day gets fired i download to the ipad uh
like a dozen his ios his monthly
investment outlooks
and i um which were fun to read i read
them all on the way home and it's like
uh you know
a forger once you get the guy's stroke
down everything looks like van gogh if
you can fake that line yeah so i sat
down and i punched out this like
hilarious
his uh bill gross's last investment
outlook and look it's not that hard you
start with a pretentious shakespeare
quote yeah you include a reference to
his cat and you talk about the fed and
interest rates and that's your your
outlook
but i purposefully made it outrageous
so that everybody would know it was
satire failing to anticipate the
bloomberg machinery would sand it down
and so we were getting you know panicked
calls from pimko how how did you get
this last oh it read very very married
whose new book the bond king called me
and said hey pimco's freaking out how'd
you get this like mary i didn't get it i
wrote it
so there was that that led to someone at
pimco was sending me
the entire bonus structure which we
subsequently wrote mary wrote the
straight reporting on it i wrote the
opinion piece on it
that led to bill gross coming on the
show so
once i had gross on i've been chasing
cliff asness who i find just so adorable
and charming and love everything he's
built and just no no everybody who says
no i'm relentless and i keep going
ah the next email from asness was
i guess if gross is on you're gonna have
to be honest after askness and gross
dalio had a book coming out in september
and after 100 knows from him he came on
yep um and so that kind of just opened
up the floodgates and now
you know it's it's i'm up to
400 or so the first 30 or 40
are not on itunes but they're somewhere
like i have the mp3s of them but yeah
yeah i have to dig them up and and post
them somewhere because i feel like the
entire set is incomplete without those
first the first six months which
admittedly the first year
i was horrible i watch it now or listen
to it now i'm awful
awful oh i don't believe that well as
you can see i like to talk
and
you have to get into a modality where
hey [ __ ] it's not about you it's not
the guest shut the [ __ ] up and ask some
questions i have a guy in the back of my
head
that's what i hear oh yeah and you have
to learn to listen to that guy um and it
took me like eight months to learn how
yeah i get these youtube comments like
danielle shut up and let's
let the guests talk and then i had a
guest once who had 20 minute answers and
you couldn't get in edgewise um 20
minute answers are better than
yup no no okay that's toxic that no that
doesn't work either um
i'm just gonna ask you the one question
because just watchers viewers
um
they're younger people they're getting
into investing
what would your advice be to somebody
coming out of college your one question
one question of your ten and we'll wrap
up with this
so so
i'm going to answer it by answering the
other question what do you know now that
you wish you knew then
of course that's the advice i requested
i would give to my younger self yeah
which is first
it's very hard to think about the long
term when you're as caught up in the
here and now as we all are when we're
younger
so
so first compounding
is
amazing and and if you understand the
value of compounding you'll understand
most of the stuff you piss money away on
is so ephemeral and so wasteful
that you should
you know i i hate when i see advice you
should put 10 of your like come on i
barely had two nickels to rub together
when i was in my 20s but that doesn't
mean i spent money responsibly
and being a little smarter about
the apartment i rented how i spent money
what i spent money on
i should have been saving
40 years ago and was not
um and so my
retirement accounts and nest eggs
think about it right had i begun
investing when i got out of college
in the mid-80s
would have done okay
um so that's number one number two
um i'm gonna give you three things so
number one you find a way to just start
investing any amount and just be aware
that savings is the first step well
no i see i never wanted to save but
invest then
no
because you don't want money sitting in
a bank account if you want more no no no
no i understand but you've got to set
aside some of what you make right that's
right
number two
and again this is advice to younger me
your first job doesn't matter what you
do
it's the network you build it's the
relationships you have it's the skill
set that you develop it's the stack of
abilities and knowledge that you're
creating you're creating a skill stack
and a knowledge base that you're going
to use for the rest of your life if you
focus on that and it doesn't matter if
you're at goldman sachs or or bob's
um house of of bonds it doesn't make a
difference as much as everybody wants
the prestigious jobs
it's not the prestige it's it's what you
build for yourself right that
you're basically going to live on for
the next
40 years i say always start in sales but
anyways that's a form of that
some people are really really bad at it
or
really are it's not their forte and it
becomes like a really unpleasant
like there are a lot of people who are
not that
outgoing a lot of my
outgoing bravado was me overcoming for
what essentially was a painfully shy of
childhood this is all
vast over-compensation so
and i know it may or may not look that
way but you know i was a quiet kid i
mean adhd and all that stuff but
like generally the adhd i believe i'm
chronically hyperactive
anyways right um and then the third
thing
and and i think this is um
i want to phrase this correctly because
this could be
misinterpreted um
we can really just leave it at those too
i'm afraid to say that
i want to phrase this
so i'm going to phrase this differently
i'm going to just alter it slightly
um
build a portfolio of people
right start start
creating a group of people
that you would work for that you would
hire that you would lend money to that
you would bury your body with like if
and and recognizing that sooner rather
than later
um and and i now have a portfolio of
people
uh that are all you know astounding
i think
the path of my career and the sort of
um the hill i had to climb would have
been easier
had i started doing that earlier yep and
sometimes you just again it's really
easy to get caught up in your head as a
20 something or even 30-something idiot
um being able to get past that and
your life is easier when it's a team
effort
that means also you know if you're
calling on people to help you you have
to be prepared to answer the call and
that happens uh
very much also accountable yes so so
having that that
you know all this comes back to
you should be always thinking about
building for the future whether it's
building a savings account building a
skill set or building a team it's always
about
to go from here to there is
it's gonna listen the time is gonna go
by whether you're doing it or not so you
might as well approach it in a way so
that when you get to 20 years 30 years
40 years hence your life is easier more
comfortable and more satisfying
than if you didn't bother with any of
those things am i is this too corny
touchy-feely stuff or no no i don't know
who your audience
is gonna watch this deep into the
conversation yeah everybody always tells
what their secrets are to success all
right everybody oh these aren't and
you're giving these are my secrets to
success these are what i wish i did
would have made my life much easier and
successfully is more easy to get then i
was an idiot i did everything the hard
way don't do it the way people say i
want advice as to how you did this i'm
like why would you want to go up the
north face of killington that's a
disaster
barry um
thank you this was it's so much fun to
interview somebody who always interviews
others
you know i just did an interview and i'm
constantly
editing myself when i'm doing the in
fact when i do a long question that's
like 30 seconds i now hear it i'm like
shut up that question is too long no one
wants to hear from you and so i've
gotten very good at just nudging people
in five ten seconds
so coming from that to this it's just
all pent up
blah blah blah well i enjoyed the pent
up thank you for coming on i really
appreciate your time my pleasure thank
you so much i thought we would talk more
about the fed i was looking forward to
arguing with you
we we can argue any day we can argue
over dinner time we can argue for dinner
tonight
thank you my pleasure
barry rit holtz ladies and gentlemen a
man who can talk but what fun to listen
to him seriously and we had peter
bookfar as an appetizer uh if you want
to hear more of peter's views then go
back watch that episode and if you want
the other fun episode that we created
here at bobby van's downtown across new
york stock exchange with arthur cash and
sir arthur himself go back and watch
that episode as well
and
watch this one to the end i'm hoping you
watch this one to the end because
barry's guidance on what he would have
done differently
is so crucial and it's so well spoken
very articulate
thank you i will see you next time on
another edition of down the middle with
demartino booth
you